[Music]
let's go to paul in birmingham what's up
paul
hey hey john what's up dude
how are you i'm good man yourself
i'm doing okay fantastic just uh glad
for the opportunity to pick your brain
about some things i'm i'm grateful man
what's up
uh well
about uh
about six years ago i got i got divorced
from my wife
uh she was having an affair
it was a
long-term affair
it was too much for me to get over at
the time so
we we got divorced
and uh
during the time that we were
separated
she had
carried on with with this other guy and
she had become pregnant
and uh
that
that all didn't work out
and
during the time that she was pregnant
i started spending a lot more time over
there with my son
kind of helping out with with the family
we had been together for
about 14 years before this before the
separation and you all had kids together
yes sir we had one okay
and uh
well just
we kind of after being divorced for
about two years we kind of rekindled
things okay
and
she had a baby girl
that i've been raising since
she was born okay
and i just
are you still with are you still with
your did you get remarried is she still
your ex-wife what's the status she's
still she's still my ex-wife we we got
back together and right now we have no
plans to get remarried okay
uh but she does live with me
and we're raising
both the kids in the house and she
carries
my daughter carries
my ex-wife's maiden name
okay
and i took her to the doctor
uh
about a month ago
and they kept calling her her last name
out and and i never responded to it i
never really even thought about it
but
then when they they approached me
and they said her her maiden name in
front of her
she didn't understand she'd never heard
that name before and she's you know
she's four and a half years old now
and it kind of
got me to thinking
about how fast she's growing and
we just
don't really know
the best way to deal with that okay
so it number one thank you for calling
number two thank you for seeing a child
in need and choosing to step into that
gap and to love this little girl and
raise her like your own it's noble okay
yes
um i'm also gonna be real direct with
you is that cool
that's cool so this is you and me just
having a drink hanging out and
um not me coming after you is that cool
yes okay
i believe
and i think the uh data would bear it
out but i believe that a person's name
is a
deeply important
um part of a person's psyche okay
um it's what anchors them
it anchors them in the present it's who
peop who people refer to them as it's
how they are known and to get really
it's going to sound woo-woo and we could
talk about the neuroscience
this idea of being known is incredibly
powerful do you know me and do you see
me and do you still love me those are
the cores to everything
everything
and
your name is how you're known it's how i
get your attention it's how we make
connection
and
it's not only the present but it's in
the past it's lineage it's this
ultimate answer to the most terrifying
question we can ask which is who am i
where am i from
and
one of the
um
one of the things that racism scholars
have taught me over the years is there's
something about having your roots torn
from the stock
and not knowing lineage
i don't know where i'm from i don't know
who might be i can't trace my lineage
back because it stops right there does
that make sense so it's a trauma not
knowing where you're from not knowing
who you are and what you're connected to
and what you're tethered to in the
modern world we've made it about
um
genetic i want to know about genetics am
i predisposed to cancers or diseases or
do my dad have bipolar those kind of
things
this is i think a much much deeper root
of thing so i tell you all that to tell
you this
your daughter's got to know her name
she's gotta know where she's from
and then oh go ahead go ahead
we we have
we've been
um
because
her biological father
has has never wanted anything to do with
her okay he
he he knows that
she
biologically is his he knows it but he
he denies her he disputes it
have you adopted her do you have a legal
claim to her
i do not well through this through the
state
uh because we looked at it um
and let me just ask you this why aren't
you getting married like what because
here's what here's the deal
uh the arc i was making
all that who's my name and what's my
lineage where am i from is all about
anchor
it's a tethering
and so i give you all the stuff about
names and anchors and all that
the single most tethering anchoring
thing for a child
is a stable mom and dad
a home
okay
a stable place to be anchored into
and y'all are playing house
well we're we're actually we're working
on the process of
the adoption uh-huh
uh because
he has to
it's complicated because there's no
signature on the birth certificate to my
knowledge we've been dealing with a
lawyer for about three years now this
should not this should not be a
three-year process should be a very very
quick process either somebody you should
your wife should have the birth
certificate or your ex-wife does she
have it
she does okay is there a signature on it
not by it uh
not by a male
just just her name is on it
yes okay that happens all the time
there's single moms all the time with
dads who suck and they don't show up
common thing so she goes to the
courthouse and you go through the
process what i don't know is depending
on what state you live in i don't know
if any old random guy which is what you
would be considered
can adopt a kid
that's right and so the right now the
judge we've we've the lawyer has
submitted uh paperwork to our
our county judge
and
she didn't respond to it so she sent it
again
and and it seems like every time she
sends it it takes months before we hear
anything back and
and it my point is i don't want to keep
anything from her
i just don't know
how
but do you understand do you understand
the chaos so that she's experiencing
and if you try to explain this like the
challenge you and i two grown educated
adults are having trying to track this
the four-year-old is going to read this
as chaos
oh no sir we don't we don't want
we don't want it anytime soon
well
let me back it up this kid
okay this kid
and here he
this is me just being straight with you
you're trying to have all sides of
you're trying to be in relationship with
this woman but not go through the hurt
again not go all in
you're going partly in yes and so you're
trying to hedge your bet against a woman
that let's be honest you love her and
she's
she's who you're spending time with she
lives with you
and you're trying to raise this kid as
though she's your own but you haven't
taken the legal steps to make her your
own so you're just playing dad
and that's an important role right now
but you're not all in
and that girl knows you're not all in
that's it so
however i can say this it's not a
cognitive thing with a four-year-old
they feel it
okay
you are the most stable male presence in
her life make no mistake and what you're
doing is a noble thing what i'm telling
you to do is that this nobility wears
off because you're you're going halfway
okay and then i would rather see you sit
down and go all in with mom again and
create a
bound home
this is who we are and where we are and
this girl will always be a part of our
lives
which means
you're gonna have to
do a lot of soul searching and forgiving
and your ex is gonna have to have some
life change which i'm assuming is all
that's happened otherwise she would be
living with you again
and we're to create that stability there
i do i i don't know what you're trying
to gain by not
connecting this thing because if you're
married this is a very simple simple
process
yes
the complexity here i don't understand
the hoop chiller jumping through that
may be three or four other phone calls
right
uh yes
but you're trying to have it all without
going all in
and all the anytime you don't go all in
and relationally it creates chaos and
then you end up with all sorts of
downstream challenges
and that's on top of
this little girl needs to know like her
her name and her origin and her
birthright and she's going to have to
grieve and deal with the fact that her
biological dad wanted nothing to do with
her which will be a soul wound as they
call it forever
and she's gonna have to learn that paul
showed up
and said i chose you
and that's a different kind of love that
she's gonna have to learn to understand
what that even means right all that to
say is that's just playing playing
that's gonna play out over the next few
years i want her to have as hardcore of
an anchor into bedrock right
yes
that's that's all i'm saying so i i
now i'm realizing as i'm talking to you
i i don't even know
if that that wasn't your question
um should i get married or not or should
i like what should i do so tell me what
your question is man how can i help well
i just
uh
my main thing was
in a perfect world
and you you kind of answered my question
is my question was this this situation
was more about my daughter because i
mean i love her she
every morning she comes in she has to
get her cuddles for daddy before she
goes to school she has to lay in bed
with me for at least 15 to 20 minutes in
the morning before she gets up and gets
ready
but
you know my thing was
uh you know i i am considering
uh remarriage i just i was i was with
this woman for seven years
before i proposed to her yeah
and
you know when the affair happened
you know it kind of
and and then i i normalized being single
for two years and and
you know kind of set my path and then
and then we rekindled things and got
back together i was never expecting that
and then you know so things are are so
much different and
uh but now they're they're kind of
normalizing again it's been can we say
this out loud something can we say this
out loud
you got hurt real bad
oh yes sir i know that's not cool for uh
for a
southern alabama guy to say out loud
that woman ripped your heart out right
yeah yeah yes sir she did okay and after
seven years you slow played seven years
because you don't want to get hurt
and for whatever reason you've got
built-in alarm systems that say dude
relationships will get you hurt it'll
get you hurt it'll get you hurt and you
finally did it and it got you hurt yes
sir right
and so here you go here you find
yourself again
so i want you to remember this line i
say it a lot on the show but i'll say it
again
all relationship a hundred percent of it
is a risk
all of it
yes and the unfortunate thing about it
is the only way
to get the beauty out of a relationship
is to go all in
and like going all in you can get hurt
don't do don't get remarried for this
little girl
get remarried because you and your and
your ex want to
build something totally new
yes sir that's
the main reason why we haven't
remarried yet why is that
because i didn't want
you know i thought about
the adoption
that that part was mainly if something
were to go wrong again between me and
her that she couldn't keep me from
from my daughter hold on
man i hate to say it like this but she's
not your daughter
yes sir i hate to be that guy dude
but she's not
okay you haven't go i mean legally she's
not your daughter your wife right now
could make one phone call and you could
never see her again
i understand right
now
in that little girl's mind in your mind
in your family's mind you are the only
dad she's ever known
and that's what i want to bring the gap
together from the reality that everybody
experiences in that home and the legal
reality and the truth reality and the
bedrock reality
and your
picture you know like it's an old
cartoon where the the ice splits
and your legs start getting further and
further apart as those ice chunks start
floating away that's where you are right
now
yes sir bring it back together
and it might mean that y'all got to go
get marriage counseling which i know is
not a cool thing to do you got to go do
something and learn
we're going to build an awesome life
together
yes sir you know what i mean
that's
hard to hear but you but you're right
what do you love this woman
oh yes yes if you propose today would
you say yes
yes sir okay
so it took you seven years
what's the hang up this time
[Laughter]
i don't know this is certainly
eye-opening so
give me plenty to think about what's the
hang up you've got to hang up
what's the hang up
you mean as to not getting married yeah
i mean she lives with you you're trying
to you're trying to connect be connected
to her for life through parenting
you see that's like no i would suppose
i'd suppose it was the process of the
divorce
was um
it killed you huh
well yeah financially and and and then
just
the amount of stress that yeah i
actually had a i had a
i had a complete and total loss of
appetite for two weeks i didn't eat
anything and i was never hungry and i'd
never experienced that before it was
stress and it's called trauma
it's called stress right
took everything from you your money your
soul your trust your heart
and
you're right back in it
yeah i guess it was just easier to
have to
as you would say play playhouse but let
me tell you something crazy now okay
this is bananas um and it was a shape
shifter moment for me
our
brains can play house we can
uh i can work at a job that i know is
like
i've got a friend who works at a job
it's a terrible job it's killing him
literally killing him but the benefits
are good
and so he says something like oh man the
benefits are good and i might have to
pay for braces for all my kids and
whatever um and that's how he wraps his
head around it i've got another friend
who drives like a lunatic
but he has some sort of rationalization
the the the title of the book by vander
kulk is this the body keeps the score
so whatever story you're telling
yourself
your body knows
okay here's what i mean by that if you
haven't made peace with the fact that
you are back into a full-fledged living
in relationship with somebody who hurt
you
that's a recipe for dying young
it's a recipe for anxiety for stress for
heightened always on edge
forgiveness on the other hand is you
taking that brick that she gave you she
handed you a cinder block and said i
take everything from you
it's you setting that cinder block down
because it's not hurting her anymore
it's hurting you and you're carrying it
around set it down
and look at her and say i'm gonna do
this again
because i think she's changed and you
think you you think you've changed and
y'all are not gonna try to reclaim what
was you're gonna build something totally
new it's gonna be amazing for you for
her for your family for this little girl
for your son for everybody
yes sir does that make sense
it does i kind of a part of me knew you
were gonna say that and here's i've been
watching your show for a while here's
what sucks
it could all happen again
yes sir i know that
she could cheat on you and hurt you
again
and the risk is
i don't think i i i think she's all in
and maybe that's the question is she all
in like are you all in
and has she given you that she
demonstrated the last couple of years
i'm all in i am all in on you
and maybe i was young and dumb and
immature
and maybe i made some dumb mistakes
maybe
after seven years of dating your first
five or six or ten years of marriage you
weren't still wearing it all in you gave
her you you know
you liked her so you put a ring on it
and uh
oh you put a ring on it and then um but
you still weren't all in
and she felt that gap and she went
somewhere else to try to fill that gap
however it is what i don't tell you is
this
it sounds
counter-intuitive
um
but the only way to make a relationship
work especially marriage to go all in
pick your feet up and just go
and the only way to get hurt uh you can
get hurt anyway you can go all in and
get hurt you can drag your feet and get
hurt the only way to make it work is to
go all in
and if she's not the one i don't want to
push you to marriage dude paul if she's
not the one
then it's time to move on
it's time to stop playing house and say
and i'm worth more than this i am going
to go have a relationship where it's
equal if you're back then forgive her
and say we're not going to play house
anymore we're going to do this thing
right and we're gonna be all in
and we're gonna give this little girl
a stability that um she might otherwise
wouldn't have had and i'll tell you
again paul you're a man of character
you stepped into a gap where most men
would run her own dad ran coward
but you didn't
let's do some soul searching and figure
out what's next
send me a wedding invitation
if it happens